Horror movies are always at their best when
the third act goes a little off the rails.
Thriller endings are supposed to leave us
feeling either satisfied or completely unsatisfied,
and nowhere in between.
So, when a scary movie actually delivers that
grand finale that ties all its terror tricks
together, it can be pretty unforgettable.
Let's take a look back at some of those horror
flicks that really stuck the landing before
the turn of the millennium.
And, it should go without saying, spoilers
for these old movies lay ahead...
The Omen
Directed by Richard Donner, The Omen features
one of the most iconic villains of all time:
Damien Thorn, a pint-sized Antichrist destined
to rule the world.
Adopted by an American ambassador, Damien
is indoctrinated by his satanic nanny.
Soon, the body count starts stacking up.
After realizing his adopted kid is actually
the son of Satan, Daddy Thorn takes Damien
to a church and plans to go full-bore biblical
on him.
We're talking Abraham and Isaac.
"No, Daddy, no!"
"God help me."
However, before he can finish the dastardly
deed, the cops show up and open fire.
After the gunsmoke clears, we cut to a funeral.
But unfortunately for mankind, Damien is alive
and well — it's Thorn who's six feet under.
And in a satanic twist of fate, Damien has
been adopted by Thorn's old buddy — the
President of the United States.
Damien looks directly at the camera and gives
an eerie smile that'd easily prevent anyone
watching from ever wanting kids.
Invasion of the Body Snatchers
In Philip Kaufman's Invasion of the Body Snatchers
remake, Donald Sutherland plays a San Francisco
health inspector named Matthew Bennell who's
drawn into a bizarre conspiracy involving
an evil alien race.
These extraterrestrials are creating doppelgängers
of every human on Earth, and their plan is
to absorb victims while they sleep and create
emotionless doubles using plant-like pods.
The process is horrifying.
Naturally, this doesn't sit well with Bennell
and his small group of survivors, who desperately
try to stay awake to avoid having their bodies
snatched.
The group also discovers they can fool the
aliens by acting cool and detached.
But if they show an ounce of emotion, the
pod people emit a high-pitched scream to alert
their fellow aliens.
It sounds like this:
(shrieking)
Bennell does his best to prevent the bad guys
from spreading their pods across the world,
but there's no stopping the invasion.
At the end of the film, it appears that Bennell
is hiding from the bad guys in plain sight,
surviving by impersonating the pod people.
But as he leaves his office one day, he runs
into an old friend who's still human...and
that's when this happens:
(shrieking)
Friday the 13th
The horror genre is full of last-minute gotcha
moments, from the graveyard dream in Carrie
to the return of Freddy in A Nightmare on
Elm Street.
But as good as those are, Friday the 13th's
finish stands decapitated head and shoulders
above the rest.
This slasher classic follows a bunch of teenage
counselors fooling around at a summer camp
when a mysterious maniac turns up, slashing
folks with every sharp instrument known to
man.
Eventually, the culprit is revealed to be
an angry Mrs. Voorhees, a former camp cook
who wants revenge against all counselors for
letting her deformed son drown in Crystal
Lake decades ago.
Luckily, final girl Alice neck-chops Mrs.
Voorhees and escapes the camp by climbing
into a canoe and sailing onto the lake.
She falls asleep before reaching the shore,
and when she wakes up, it's a beautiful day,
the cops have arrived, and it seems like she's
finally safe.
And that's when a waterlogged Jason jumps
out of the lake and pulls Alice down with
him.
Alice later wakes up in a hospital, with no
sign of Jason anywhere.
But she's not convinced he was some figment
of her fatigued imagination.
"Then he's still there."
No one believed her then — but the dozen
films to follow certainly proved she was right
about that.
The Thing
Directed by John Carpenter, The Thing is a
brutally cynical sci-fi film that follows
a group of American scientists trapped inside
an Antarctic research station.
They're being hunted by a shapeshifting alien
that absorbs its victims and creates identical
copies, so in addition to battling this otherworldly
beast, our heroes are also dealing with a
serious case of paranoia.
By the film's last act, the titular thing
has slain almost everyone in the camp, with
the exception of MacReady, a bearded helicopter
pilot who blows the creature to kingdom come.
Unfortunately, he sets the entire base on
fire in the process.
As he sits alone in the wreckage, that's when
Childs, MacReady's old frenemy steps in.
The guy vanished during the climactic showdown
with the thing, and now MacReady isn't sure
if Childs is human anymore.
The two are in a standoff, and as the cold
sets in, they share a bottle of whiskey and
wait for someone — or something — to make
the next move, leaving us to wonder if our
heroes will make it out alive…or if they're
even heroes anymore.
"If we've got any surprises for each other,
I don't think we're in much shape to do anything
about it."
If you're gonna punctuate a pic with a question
mark, this is how it's done.
Don't Look Now
After their daughter tragically drowns at
their English estate, John and Laura Baxter
find themselves trapped in a spiral of grief.
Devastated, they move to Venice, where they
encounter two creepy sisters who claim they
can see the little girl's spirit.
Laura believes the psychic siblings, but John
is skeptical.
Nevertheless, he does notice that something
weird is going on.
There's a mysterious little figure running
around town, wearing the same red coat his
daughter had on when she drowned.
There are also rumors of a serial slayer in
the area.
Stranger still, after his wife returns to
England on an emergency visit, John inexplicably
spots her riding a funeral boat down a Venetian
canal.
John's unease grows, until he spots the girl
in red one last time.
Hoping that maybe it's the ghost of his daughter,
he follows the cloaked figure...only to realize
it's actually a monstrous dwarf armed with
a meat cleaver!
This is who's been dropping victims in the
Grand Canal.
She plants her knife right into John's neck,
and as his body violently convulses, John
realizes the vision of his wife on a funeral
boat was actually a premonition of his own
demise.
But there's nothing he can about it as he
bleeds out on the floor — a victim of grief,
guilt, and one ugly monster.
Talk about a tragic twist.
In the Mouth of Madness
Equal parts H.P.
Lovecraft and Stephen King, In the Mouth of
Madness will make you feel like you're losing
your mind.
In it, John Trent is an insurance investigator
hired by a publishing company to track down
bestselling author Sutter Cane.
The writer has mysteriously vanished, taking
his new novel with him.
But as Trent digs deeper into the case, he
learns that Cane is no average author.
See, Cane has millions of loyal followers
around the world who worship his novels...which
gives him the power to bring his characters
to life.
Worse still, Cane's new book will drive people
mad and turn them into monsters.
It's all part of his scheme to destroy the
human race and subject humanity to the rule
of ancient gods.
But before Cane can accomplish his plan, he
wants Trent to deliver his now-finished manuscript
to his publisher… and Trent has to obey
because he's actually one of Cane's characters.
Obviously, Trent refuses to believe he was
dreamed up for some book.
But soon enough, Cane's novel has turned the
world into a mutated madhouse.
With society crumbling around him and his
mind slowly slipping, Trent winds up in a
movie theater and watches the film adaptation
of Cane's book.
As it turns out, Trent is the main character
and everything that's just happened to him
is playing on the big screen.
Realizing his life is a Sutter Cane creation,
Trent snaps, laughing hysterically before
weeping uncontrollably.
But hey!
At least he has the entire theater to himself.
The Blair Witch Project
Nearly 20 years later, it's easy to forget
how big a deal The Blair Witch Project was
when it first debuted in 1999.
It revolutionized viral marketing, introduced
the found footage fad to the mainstream, and
totally messed people up with its incredibly
freaky ending.
After heading into the woods to make a documentary
about the local legend of the Blair Witch,
three college students — Heather, Mike,
and Josh — find themselves completely lost
and wandering in circles.
"I gave you the map!"
"I gave you back the map!"
They soon discover spooky stick figures hanging
from branches, hear creepy kids giggling at
night, and then Josh mysteriously disappears,
leaving only a few teeth and a piece of his
tongue behind.
Soon after, Mike and Heather hear him screaming
in the distance, and they follow the sound
to an abandoned house.
Camera in hand, Heather makes her way into
the basement and finds her friend standing
in a corner…which is how a child slayer
of local legend would position his victims.
That's when someone — or something — attacks
her from behind and the camera falls to the
ground, still recording for several seconds
before it stops.
Psycho
It's a bit of a shock in Psycho when the main
character, Marion Crane, is suddenly and violently
dispatched in the middle of the film.
But things take an even crazier turn when
it's revealed that the culprit is hotel manager
Norman Bates in drag.
Having offed his own mother years ago, the
disturbed motel clerk suffers from a split
personality that causes him to act like his
evil mom and stab unsuspecting victims as
they shower.
"We all go a little mad sometimes."
Norman is eventually captured and tossed into
a cell, where he completely transforms into
his domineering mother.
Huddled beneath a blanket with his mom's voice
running through his head, Norman looks at
the audience and gives a chilling grin, as
Mrs. Bates' skull flashes over his face, proving
that there is no more Norman — only Mom.
We then cut back to the Bates Motel, where
the cops are towing Marion's car out of a
swamp, leaving the viewer to wonder how many
more cars will be found down there.
Night of the Living Dead
This seminal zombie film has a simple plot:
one fateful day, corpses rise up from the
ground — and boy, are they hungry.
Soon, a small band of survivors find themselves
trapped inside an old farmhouse, desperately
fighting the zombie horde, not to mention
their own growing fears and rivalries.
Eventually, there's only one survivor left,
a black man named Ben, who wakes up the next
morning after hearing a volley of gunshots
in the distance.
Cautious but hopeful, Ben peers out the window,
spotting an all-white posse outside.
Suddenly, the gun-toting group sees Ben, and
assuming he's a zombie, a gunman puts a bullet
in his head.
Having survived an assault by an army of flesh-hungry
fiends, our hero is ultimately defeated by
the very people who were supposed to keep
him safe.
"Okay, he's dead.
Let's go get him.
That's another one for the fire."
There are a lot of social and political undertones
that can be drawn from the ending.
But the film lets the scene speak for itself
— a stroke of brilliance on director George
A. Romero's part.
The Sixth Sense
In the movie that put M. Night Shyamalan on
the map, we meet child psychologist Malcolm
Crowe, who has some unfinished business to
attend to.
Years after failing to help a young patient
suffering from hallucinations, he gets a shot
at redemption in the form of nine-year-old
Cole Sear.
And folks, Cole has a heck of a problem:
"I see dead people."
Cole reveals that the people he sees don't
know they aren't alive.
And while the doctor is skeptical at first,
he quickly learns the boy really does possess,
well, a sixth sense.
Realizing the spirits might need help, Crowe
encourages Cole to communicate with the ghosts
and come to terms with his gift.
Meanwhile, Crowe has grown distant from his
wife, and at the end of the movie, he sits
beside his sleeping bride — which is when
the director's famous knack for twists kicks
in.
In her sleep, Crowe's wife asks why he left
her and then drops something on the floor.
It's Crowe's wedding ring…the one he thought
he was wearing during the whole film.
Suddenly Crowe remembers that a disgruntled
patient — the one he'd failed so long ago
— actually ended his life before doing the
same to himself.
Crowe's been a ghost all along, and the clues
were everywhere.
It doesn't get much better than that.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!